good morning Hank it's Friday it's also
117 thousand degrees outside Celsius and
like a boss I decided to go for a walk
do you know what the most common
irrigated crop in the United States is
turf grass you know there's three times
more irrigated turf grass and you know I
can't do this
I do hot it is hotter than Kim jong-il
would be if he died and went to hell yet
more evidence Hank that outside is
overrated right so there's three times
more irrigated turf grass in the United
States and there is corn but more
importantly almost all of the water that
we irrigate turf grass with is potable
about 30 percent of the overall drinking
water supply and America goes to feed
grass hey it seems to me that the
American front lawn is the best possible
example of how what is called status quo
bias can lead to like complete insanity
I mean obviously front lawns are a
terrible idea I mean Hank what do all of
these front lawns have in common no one
is using them they're just sitting there
sucking 4 billion gallons of drinking
water every frakking day also in order
to maintain this completely unnatural
plant monoculture we use 70 million
pounds of pesticides every year on our
grass grass which I will remind you does
not feed us I'm sorry but it is very hot
and just like characters in Victorian
novels the temperature reflects my
temperament 70 million pounds of
pesticides a year it's ridiculous and
the most ridiculous part is that I'm out
there with them trying to make sure that
my grass looks ok so my neighbors don't
get mad at me I think there are some
advantages to lawns grass turns carbon
dioxide into oxygen although it's hardly
the most efficient carbon sink and
there's some soil erosion benefits
although we'd all be better off if we
had like a big mix of plants in our
front yard and we'd be better off still
if we had vegetable gardens so how did
we end up with the disaster that is the
front lawn
the British that's right Hank we threw
off their colonial yoke and said no to
taxation without representation but they
got us on the lawn so on is a British
invention but the idea isn't as crazy in
Britain because as you know it rains all
the freakin time so they don't have to
pump 4 billion gallons of drinking water
every day into their lawns on the
downside they never get to see the Sun
and also James Murdoch so Hank we're all
biased toward the status quo not to beat
a dead horse but that's the only reason
we still have pennies like if someone
tried to introduce a coin that was worth
a thousandth of a dollar today people
would be
that's insane well it's equally insane
to have a coin that's worth a hundredth
of a dollar but since it already exists
we're all ok with it
- link if you can close your eyes and
imagine a world in which there's a huge
vegetable garden in the front of every
home in suburban America and there's a
multi-billion dollar industry of people
taking care of these vegetable gardens
and watering them and helping you to
harvest the crops your food costs go
down you have more vegetables in your
diet we use less oil and gas to
transport food but then one day you
decide to rip up your vegetable garden
and become the first person in your
neighborhood to lay down turf grass your
neighbors are gonna come over and be
like hey what's the new thing and you'll
be like that's turf grass and they'll be
like great
what do you cook it with and you know
you don't eat it in short Hank your
neighbors are gonna think you're crazy
partly because they have status quo bias
toward this world in which all front
yards are composed of vegetable gardens
and partly because they're right but
Hank the weirdest thing about status quo
bias is that it doesn't actually
preserve the status quo over the last 40
years American lawns have gotten bigger
and bigger and bigger and bigger we're
trying to preserve the status quo and we
have an idea in our head that's fueled
by advertising that long should be
massive I know this Hank because it
happened to me when we moved to
Indianapolis I was like Sarah we've got
to get a huge yard I want a riding
lawnmower and she was like you are not
going to enjoy mowing the lawn and I was
like I'm gonna love mowing the lawn yeah
so long story short the heat index is
114 degrees and I have to go mow the
lawn Hank I'll see you on Monday